all right cookies we're going on at
Timmy Ron we're athletes to need for
this scary ball oh how scary could it Oh
No Oh hard wrestling well I bow to your
um I am happy ball throw oh my goodness
it's actually a really well-made ball
throw dammit
alright guys let's try this again angle
neon bottle run okay what is going on
here like as per usual I know what I'm
doing thank you some more balls thank
you yes please can I thank you
um uh I don't quit the bottle runs let
me tell you that right now
[Applause]
please thank you
are you very much credit alright we're
on the sea adventure this is the word
I'm looking boats hope we don't treat it
wrongly put on the front of the boat
ready you'll be my little mermaid Pogo
Adventure shortcut way oh this doesn't
look good oh hang on hang on hang on
hang on hang on getting my head in there
this does not know where no no no
no make a move I'm going to do tricks
watermelon
welcome to rope swing of Awesomeness I
doubt it's any more awesome than any of
the other rope swings that I've seen in
my abilities not that kind of fun either
we're gonna do a little jump oh no poor
balls are escaping the box huh
okay just gotta thrust my hips oh yeah
get it get it get it a thrust it my oh
yeah you like that cannon you like no
way look at my sensual dance though
right welcome to these to the human
break that's what happened to all the
bad else who don't do what I tell them
to do
hang on hang on I'm doing my rhythmic
movements my gyrating hips will turn you
on like you never sink no wait I need to
turn you off huh what can I do that's
not sexy walking to work getting a lot
of what now I'll save you not worth that
huh I'm not going I'm not going in there
for all the money in the world you can't
make me you go you go you go first and
now I go the unbeaten tests part 1
spikes for annoying son I have no son
mrs. Claus wouldn't wanna help children
seem to be ok oh this is about the least
exciting race I've ever been on in my
entire life
[Music]
maava run extreme oh well that was easy
whoa ha ha there's a few arrows being
shot towards us a little kid you're
gonna be okay over there oh my balls but
that's good I didn't need my balls
anyway Gary Walter no joke
Oh in the wind oh yes I am the greatest
ever this game that's where sward
assassin oh ha ha
horsie kasi ha ha I didn't kill my
target I'm Phil Bob oh my god Sara what
have you done
kill Indiana Jones easy oh no my gone
out I'm trying to get it with my
ding-dong
but it's just not grabbing damn it I was
young again this one is an impossible
our pool run everybody we lost one go go
go oh no no no put me back up pull me
Scooby along with your with your nubile
young body hold me hold me close no
these guys think they know what's up
they do not I am the best
I'm the greatest ever oh lost my kid
yeah whatever I have to pay any more
child support
no dude I swore throw it's fun I'll be
the judge of what's fun and what's not
throw in the baby tub hip hip hip hip
and yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm not really
throwing it I'm just trying to play with
it a little bit yeah let's do this again
but much more quickly er let's not get
slowed down please
we gotta move we gotta move silly
billina's wait weird the rainbow go oh
haha oh my god
how are my legs working so wrong get
away get away get away
how are my arms still working kill the
zombies kill the zombies with what this
oh it's a cannon sweet kill him
hahaha one more for the ha ah ha
what what Oh this kind of is painful but
ok here we go kills us zombies
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you like with
your son you want to see more why not
subscribe to my channel want to help the
channel grow
leave a like add it to your favorites or
share it with your friends on Facebook
and Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]